well as sixth bomb blast appears to have
just rocked Austin Texas injuring at
least one person police are
investigating another package they say
it's suspicious it could be an explosive
they don't know yet
Casey steagle is in Austin right now
covering the manhunt for the bomber and
who joins us with the latest Casey yeah
Tucker unbelievable we got off the air
with you at the top of the hour and now
here we are in a different spot because
a sixth bomb has gone off in Austin and
it is in South Austin too this time we
are at the intersection of Brodie Lane
and slaughter Lane and this is actually
pretty close to the bomb site on Sunday
we're only about six miles away the one
that had the trip wire on it so you see
a real heavy police activity in the area
right now
we've got us pushed back pretty far
because clearly it's a fluid and
dangerous situation they want to keep
everyone including the public who's
gathering to take pictures and see all
of this for themselves they want to keep
them safe we know that it was at a
goodwill whether it was inside outside
that is unclear at this point but we
know it was a goodwill because when the
dispatch call went out we matched the
address and my producer was able to
contact goodwill locally and the woman
was very upset on the phone saying that
it was one of their workers so one
person injured it is not
life-threatening so that is the latest
here as police are now dealing with a
sixth bombing tonight in Texas Capitol
City Tucker shotgun Casey thanks to that
I appreciate it